today I just want to work on end games
with you okay and just set up many
in-game positions and explain to you how
to win certain endgame positions because
you know openings you can study it's
easier but I find it more difficult to
study end games because you need to know
which positions are important and which
positions you can use certain ideas so
the first example I have for you is the
position on the screen we have obviously
it's a huge advantage here for white I
mean white is just dominating with a
bishop there the roof on a 7th rank
extra piece but there is a problem there
is a problem here the problem is f7 pawn
our G Phi upon this week and he's gonna
take it so if let's say we make a move
he takes our last pawn and even though
we win the pawn here this is a
theoretically drawn position so I mean
you can still can try to win this but
objectively speaking this is a draw okay
if both sides play correctly this is a
draw okay so that's why in this position
you have a one chance here and one
opportunity here to get to the winning
end game so what do you think what I can
do here to try to win this game because
if you lose your g5 part that's it it's
gonna be a draw so you cannot afford to
lose the g5 pawn
so it's very important I want to give a
few minutes to everyone so they can
think few minutes for everyone to think
and then we're gonna you can raise your
hands in two three minutes so we can see
if you have the correct answer here
the key is for us somehow to keep our
upon ng5 okay we want to keep that fun
okay well you have i'm trading to win
your pawn and if somehow I win your pawn
you are not going to win this game
remember if I win your pant you are not
going to win this game okay so that's
the idea yeah
so think about it
okay now you can raise your hands if you
have the winning idea here yes you could
do that but I take your last pun wait
wait wait wait rope three six and I take
your last ponent I know you can take
this wait wait wait
okay of seven and then this will be you
know you still can't play but it's a
draw Luke f7 doesn't change much I just
walking to h6 okay so look at CERN I
just cooking h6n it doesn't change I
mean
okay so what is the move you're
suggesting Kish aha if I take your rook
and I take your Bishop then focus focus
you actually you actually find the right
idea okay let's let's make sure let's
raise your raise our hands if we have
you know an answer to say okay so make
sure that's how we do it
so you actually found the right idea but
you need to know how to finish it up
from now okay so you actually did find
rook f7 that's the only winning move is
rook f7 here because we cannot allow him
to take our upon so now he takes we
exchange he takes and now you need to
make a move and get the position you
make a move and you get an opposition
here wait wait let me call you first
yeah you just raise your hand first yes
next
okay very good
how are we gonna do that we need to make
a special move here without this move we
cannot win here so what is your move
here yes but please wait until I call
you okay yeah no no I was still do you
have a move on oh okay
yeah but how here here no no see only
one move here will give you the win only
one move here anything else it's gonna
be a draw anything else will be a draw
so what can we do here to make the
correct move here okay what is the move
King g5 the problem as he goes King e7
and he gets the opposition and the kinks
are in front of each other and it's an
opposition okay if you go here he goes
here okay so but you have a better move
you think about it you have a little
better move here that you can make this
move and you have the opposition you
have what's called diagonal opposition
there is a regular opposition there is a
diagonal and there is a distant
opposition okay so what's the move King
d5 okay great
now diagonal opposition
so black goes here now we get the
regular opposition now it goes here now
what is the next poll raise your hands
okay if you know them over is your hand
yes in the back didn't huh
King d6 correct now basically you will
be pushing the King away from his pawn
and when you push him away then you're
gonna win the pawn okay now he goes here
now what is the move here and how we can
get closer how we can get closer so we
can win the pawn here everybody should
try to participate okay
even if you're not absolutely sure about
the move try try to find ideas yes
correct now goes here continue now what
is the move here yes absolutely
King h7 and now sit properly
now what is the move here yes of course
king f7 King h8 and now we're gonna win
the pawn already right now he goes it ok
here don't think you already won the
game here because you still need to find
a correct move here if you don't find a
correct move now they're good chances
for him to make a draw so you have to
play the best move here if you don't
play the best move then you could
actually he could still make a draw here
well what is the best one here yes which
move this is c2
now this is a position you have the
wrong position there yeah you have the
board upside down so you need to change
the board
so what's them where do we go with the
King here okay let's see okay
correct yes correct only winning move in
this position is the move King h6 okay
anything else it's a good drawing
chances for him yeah I know it looks
like f6 could win too but the problem is
with this one he goes here yes but then
he has this trick still mate what is
still mate everybody here know what is
still made excellent everybody know the
still mate right so that's why you could
be winning but if you rush you think I'm
winning anyway now I'll quickly play
people play all the time quick quick
quick and then they they instead of
winning they drew the game okay
great now we know this so that's why
don't play King f-16 you go King to h6
because you want to make sure you leave
it open for him to escape so he can go
away you don't want him to be stuck in a
corner because if he's stuck in a corner
he will have drawing chances we don't
want him to have those drawing chances
okay so that's why we don't want it that
now King age six he goes King to h8
was came to h8 now continued perfect
King g8 remember we need to make sure we
can promote our opponent to a queen and
here we can accomplish that by doing
which move pawn to g7 now King cannot go
anywhere has to go here and now we
control the g8 squared by playing kink
h7 and we promote our upon into a queen
and we win the game okay so remember
it's this the only way for you to win
this position okay so remember in this
kind of positions if you're punished on
a fifth rank fifth rank and black pawn
is on a sixth rank if you can win his
pawn on g4 b c d e f g this files it's a
win for you if it's a corner it's a draw
because corner pawns are not good but
any of this scores even if even if he
gets the opposition here right see he
looks like he gets the opposition but
your pawn is already too far advanced so
he cannot do anything okay so it's like
over remember the h6 square okay
and then you went and next next position
basically a very similar position but I
move the black pass one one line up now
can we do the same idea you think can we
do the same idea and win the game so you
need to understand the difference
between like pawn being on a fort okay
and pawn being on a fifth it's a big
difference here
so he's still trying to win the pond but
what can you do here if you lose your
pond it will be a draw yeah so it's
gonna take your pond so if you go here
he just takes not gonna work so we try
to do the same thing with it earlier
right we take he takes takes takes and
we get a diagonal opposition right so it
looks like okay why can't we win this
time I mean we're still gonna be able to
win the pond here but you will see the
difference now King goes only six king
efore King f6 King to five again pushing
the king away from the pond but the
problem we have here is his pawn is
actually further advanced than in the
previous position and here he is gonna
be able to make a draw by getting the
opposition because he's got the extra
row here which is very important early a
position he didn't have that but now by
having that extra row it's like extra
square he has and now we cannot win this
position so King goes here same thing
like in the other example you push you
push now you go to g8 he comes up here
and you push three he gets to steal made
okay so remember in this positions if he
pushes you go always in front of the
pawn okay always when you retreat here's
the passport going down alone passport
he pushes you go back okay you go back
to face the pawn okay that's what you
need to do okay so you go back to g8 he
steps up then you get the opposition you
push us then you go here and it's a
stalemate okay okay that's very very
good
comfortable position okay
so rook f6 in this position it
this position is already a draw because
your your pawn is on a four track it
needs to be on the fifth track then only
you can win this okay okay next position
now let's take a look at this position
you are playing with the white pieces
and you have two extra pounds do you
think this is enough to win or you think
still black can draw this position it's
enough to win correct
give this enough to win but it's it's
tricky first I'm going to show you the
win and then I'll show you the position
very similar this pawn will just be here
and he has good drawing chances so the
question is how do we win the position
like this so you need to improve the
position first of all so first you have
to improve the position remember and you
have a passed pawn and that passed pawn
is protected by the rook so what you
need to do here is to try to advance
that pawn as far as you can it's a plum
clear the first step of our plan we got
the passed pawn rook is protecting is
advanced upon as far as possible
simple push it's gonna sit push example
he sits and push but you can ask me okay
what we do next
we cannot move our rook he will take our
pond so now our rook is stuck now we
need to move our other pawn yes so we
push so he's gonna check we can go away
he's gonna check you go away check you
go away
okay go yeah there he goes here for
example it now looks like again problem
we can't move our rook because remember
if we lose this pawn without winning his
rook we cannot win this position but he
is also tied up to this palm because if
it goes away somehow then you simply
move the rook away and promote the pawn
so rook actually cannot be protecting
this both pawns so now
what do we do yes which one
absolutely we sacrificed upon how yes f5
and as I mentioned if he takes the pawn
you simply move the rook and then
promote if he goes here
we promote takes and take everybody here
in this room know how to checkmate with
the rook with one rook okay which raise
your hands if you know how to win with
the rook
okay okay well most of most of the
students know it but few students are
not raising their hand so I will quickly
show how to win to check man with the
rook okay it's a very simple concept
okay you know and and you you guys who
raise your hands if you think you know
it this might be a little bit different
so you can learn another way how to
checkmate okay
so let's finish this position first
before we move on to that one what if it
doesn't take what if he is sitting what
do we do dink-dink first okay
don't don't think about it
yes what is the move correct check again
he cannot move the rook because you move
this away okay and then you promote and
if the King takes it do you see it
do you see a good move here check yes
check King goes away promote promote our
rook again that's why you have to know
exactly how to check me with the rook
because many end games you play the
final position is going to be going to
have a rope and you need to know the
technique how to win those positions
properly and the last idea he can do if
he goes away you just push what if he
puts the blockade on what if he is
blockading it what if he is blackening
and now strong move you have here very
strong move
very strong move yes check here I take
and see I'm still controlling this pawn
still control you have something better
here you have something stronger you
make a strong move and then you get the
rook you make a very strong when you get
the rook let's see who is gonna find
this idea this is a very common idea in
this type of positions where you have
past pounds in fact we are this idea you
cannot win this position this is the
only idea you can use to win it with
dink dink you're going to be able to win
his rook here in just few moves few
moves he would like to three moves you
win his rook and then again we're gonna
practice the checkmate with the rook to
make sure you know the best way how to
do it the most efficient way how to
check me with a rock yes wait it's white
to move you're trying to play for white
but you can go only b8 but then you go
to b8 I take your pawn if we lose that
pawn we will we cannot win in that
position okay who knows the tactical
idea cause skewer few few students know
it okay
can you find that idea here that we can
do to skewer his rook and win the game
okay yes correct answer rook
h8 promoting the pawn until a queen now
he is forced to take that pawn and once
he takes it
haha very good and what do we call this
idea what is this idea call this tactic
skewer pain is different okay
he takes focus and now again we reach
this position okay so remember this is
the in this position we gonna get this
okay okay so we got this there are two
ways to checkmate the way I'm gonna
teach you is the best way to checkmate
okay the most efficient way to checkmate
now so let's say black was here this is
this is probably one of the worst
positions that you could have to check
me with a rock I mean the longest okay
so what you do in this position is you
cut the king we use the cut idea again
so the best way to do it is just cut now
this king should never be able to cross
okay like you shouldn't allow him in the
middle to cross down okay so you haven't
cut like this so he's gonna sit let's
count how many move that's one right
that's one move so that's one move
complete now you come up now he goes
here that's true
now that's cut that's another cut see
that's three moves only but we already
got him with cut now that means he
cannot even cross here in this game and
he cannot cross here so we're aiming to
check minium right here this is where we
want to push the king slowly okay in the
books they recommend other ways to do it
but this is I think pretty easy and very
much quicker than other ways to do it so
that's three moves completed now you get
closer
four five now what is the correct move
here
yes
and what is this idea called
cut now we can't see slowly you take
away it looks like there's so many
squares on the board and King can go
back and forth all the time but no you
just with your king and rook you control
the squares over the King and he cannot
do anything so if you goes here it just
easy you cut again so he's probably
gonna go here now when he goes back we
gotta get use our King now to go forward
okay so we step up again we keep the cut
so he cannot cross now he goes here now
we wanna our goal is to push into the
background okay or on the side here on
the background goat on the side so we
say check now if he goes here this is
the worst move here for him checkmate in
two can you see it
want to checkmate in two
want to checkmate into yes your king is
perfect all you got to do here is just
make a waiting move here okay but
without touching the King okay just a
waiting move you know and then his King
is gonna go exactly where you want that
King to be and then you're gonna say
checkmate can you make that waiting move
here now here's a squirt to go so what
is that waiting move can you can you
stop with that clock yeah don't touch
the clock now what is the move here yes
what is the waiting move if I've the
thing is if you check that changes the
position you know that's not a waiting
move if you check me because then I can
go somewhere so we actually it our rook
is perfect in the King they both
perfectly placed but we don't want to
check we don't want to check we want to
make a waiting move what could be a
waiting move yes aha but wait if you go
here I can take you right
so don't do that don't do that yeah you
want to do that next move here wait wait
would that move okay yes f 6 d 6 c 6a 6b
6 all the squares are great okay
f 6 was suggested now he steps up and
now which would we play okay okay
rook age six now he has to go back now
as I show you if you go see you get
check very quickly now King goes back
your King steps up remember his skin
goes back you step up now he goes here's
same concept check we're very close now
to get the checkmate if he goes now here
what do you do to move checkmate here
how the waiting will remember the
waiting move okay the key to remember is
the waiting move he goes here checkmate
he goes to f8 now I goes here King g8
and now check mate in three one two
three
yes
correct King h7 now we got him exactly
where we want him to be we've done this
many times now already today what kind
of idea we need waiting move waiting
move okay that's the idea to remember
okay Rock d8
oka and as soon as Kings are in front of
each other
we simply play rook h8 mate okay
excellent
very very good now I want to do some
exercises this position is blocked to
play okay
and looks like block is about to lose
the game because it's just going to come
back here and do a checkmate
why wants to come back here and just say
checkmate and looks like it's a problem
looks like maybe block should resign now
or in just few more moves when he just
loses the game you know I like to play
black to play and you can have a chance
to save this game actually you can
salvage the game and get a half point
here we have two checks here right so we
have two checks okay well let's see we
have two different checks but let's
think about a little bit because it's
nice this is a very nice defensive idea
that you can try to do okay so remember
is a very good nice defensive idea okay
you want to try which take but I take
then you down a rock and then it's
winning because of the you know mating
idea white is going this way okay let's
see yellow how about this check
he has to take if he goes away then you
know we can go here and we are we are
okay you know we're safe relatively so
he takes and now can block make a legal
move here
can he make a legal move in this
position No
then what do we call this still make
buck gets a half point here draw this is
a very important idea of course of
course
well here you always want to win but you
have to look at the positions and see if
you have chances to win here no chances
to win but you know definitely I mean
it's if you don't find this move here
it's just gonna be a game over after
okay a check okay all right excellent
the a very good idea okay now the next
position so this one is just rook p7 and
it's a draw next position here
white white it's actually black to play
here okay
black to play who can find the winning
idea here for plug Bacchus down upon but
he's going to be able to win this game
because of a very nice tactical idea
because a very nice tactical idea
we take advantage of the the poor
placement of the king the king is poorly
placed and here with this nice tactical
idea we're going to be able to win a
piece and eventually the game okay
everybody thinking trying to find it
okay we have few students who are
raising their hands that's very good
okay yes
sacrificing the rook for a bishop that's
not an equal exchange right so he's
sacrificing because it's uneven exchange
a he gives up a rock queen has to take
absolutely has to take yes but is it so
you sacrifice material but you gain more
okay at the end now he takes and we win
the Queen and the game okay yeah yeah
but still the value of the Queen is nine
rookies 5 so we have materialized a huge
material advantage for black so again we
take the bishop eliminating the defender
he takes back and then we go Bishop D
for picking up the rook they're picking
up the pawn and now we have a absolute
pin and King cannot move its check and
cannot do anything
games over